un lieu plutôt insolite pour un tournage
dans les allées de ce cimetière de la
verrière on tourne le premier épisode
une websérie intitulée r&r rêve et
réalité aux commandes tony chasselas un
réalisateur verrier roi de 35 ans on à
lui casser un journaliste local qui
vient de perdre son grand père et la
perte de son grand-père et touche
énormément
ce qui se passe c'est que
il commence à faire des rêves et les
rêves se demande si ses rêves sont
réelles en fait ne souhaitant pas
dévoiler l'intrigué le réalisateur n'en
dira pas plus sur le scénario de cette
web série qui comptera huit épisodes de
12 minutes
j'ai lu le scénario et j'ai tout de
suite fait l'histoire du coup je me suis
dit ok c'est parti on y va c'est un
match plus près voilà il ya beaucoup de
films qui se sont inspirés de tous ces
gens-là différentes aux différentes
dimensions et tout ça ça me plaît c'est
de la sf mais s'est fait de manière
assez subtil et c'est assez bien écrit
en même temps du coup c'est pour ça que
ça me plaisait de de faire partie de ce
projet
ce n'est pas le premier projet
cinématographique pour tony chasse la
télé 60,18 l'avait suivie en novembre
2010 est sur le tournage de l'un de ses
courts métrages ces retraits meurtre en
verlan pour cette web série le
réalisateur a fait uniquement travailler
son imagination
les personnages y sont totalement fictif
je me suis même pas inspiré de quelqu'un
qui existait ou quoi c'est vraiment tout
ce que j'ai dans la tête c'est un
mélange de tout ce que j'ai que que je
mets à sur papier comme ça une partie de
la série sera également tourné à
coignières elle sera ensuite diffusée
sur les plates formes de streaming